yo welcome to this video playing what
yeah let's play the French I didn't do
this for wall it's a five-minute game
again against some some no region like a
guy yeah it's a French buddy never saw
that before now you we had a microphone
on the other side who would hear the
turning of book pages is looking up a
line maybe maybe not yeah the gambit c5
and before I always played this move
didn't want to look at this game but
it's not it's not too great for white
but I never bought the two to look at it
yeah this is unheard of after four moves
I'm almost 1 minute up on the clock so
we transpose into a regular French
advanced variation
yeah castles a three-down many moves on
possible yeah do you play this or do you
play some other move make them take the
airplane either fire well not so quickly
might capture with the night it's not
good but still possibility okay night at
five yeah now probably a 93 years plate
no it is not yeah it seems that he
intends to gather the deep on with the
bishop on be too yeah of course so it's
playable still I always feel that the
bishop is more actively placed on on
this diagonals you want to see one to
each age six so is this a position where
you can play g5 h5 stuff here and i'll
try that come on if he goes Bishop d3
attacking this night i can just take
deform and h5 is intending g5g five
instantly could have played g for
himself I didn't want that so here we go
how do you protect your deep own now g4
as a threat
okay he wants to go back somewhere to e1
so I want a bit of space do you play f6
even attacking it's very shaky if f6
looks like like a shaky move the bad
thing is i mean this this pawn is really
under tech I mean I just need one more
piece queen to be 60 but he's got the
night on a four unfortunately
I'm just wondering what I would be five
here be five not a Bishop b5 I play
Knight takes e4 this is probably good
for me if he plays Knight c5a come on
let's do this place tonight c5 I can
take e 5 also or take c5 is both
interesting or take deform takes d4
looks looks looks good right why not
just grabbing this pawn I can take on e
2 with check that's the point he takes
d4 i take c 50 this was this was an
early resign I mean okay it looks it
looks very good young but yeah minus one
point seven or something by the comp at
least that didn't overlook something
yeah it looks it looks good yeah I'm
just winning the pawn it sometimes
happens and the French it wants I
thought so this this is pretty pretty
straightforward the the good thing is
that also this is just a brilliant night
it's not in any way possible that that
you text it it's just unassailable on
the square and if he if he takes here I
can yeah computer wants to take on
before I intended this move at least
this is what I saw and it is just an
extra porn it's not much compensation
for white the comp actually wants to
take here yeah why not this is probably
even bateria understandable something
like this
yeah why Dwight can continue but it's
really just a pawn I have many pawns
move so making is slightly exposed but
this can be a problem in the Blitz game
but objectively this should be a billing
winning position almost yeah thanks for
watching this admittedly rather short
game